a Brit and an American swap countries to
try each other's McDonald's this is food
Wars
we'll start with some things you can't
find in the UK but I think might be
slightly different over here let's start
with the iconic McDonald's Big Mac so I
mean visually looks pretty much the same
you've got the quite sad flimsy beef
patties let's give it a try
I think there are some subtle
differences there actually like broadly
speaking if you gave it to me and we're
like this is a UK Big Mac I don't think
I would doubt you I think it's the
source because the UK Big Mac sauce
it's got like quite a Tang to it almost
and this is very gentle I barely get
anything from it the big Magna this
looks exactly like a Big Mac anywhere in
the world you know what I gotta do
I ask is this a shot
if that isn't exactly the same it's
close I mean if I could do one side by
side you'll probably notice but
I remember when we did fast food
chemistry you guys like had more
chemicals and stuff to use but I'm here
to say the chemicals have not made a
striking difference uh it tastes almost
exactly the same then we're into the
fries and the coke aspect of the meal
firstly I have to point out how enormous
these are the size of this drink is
ridiculous this is way bigger than
almost any fast food drink I've seen in
the UK ever even the fries as well like
this box of fries is used they're kind
of like sunk down a little bit so it
doesn't really show how full it was but
like this carton is massive you can fit
so many fries in it it feels like almost
double the size of a carton of UK fries
I mean these are pretty good I will say
I think they've held up a lot better
after like a bit of time out of the
fryer than UK fries have UK McDonald's
fries I think maybe because they don't
have as many ingredients there aren't
the kind of like preservative chemicals
in there they don't really hold up very
well at all as soon as they come out the
fryer they kind of just get worse and
worse and worse so you have to eat them
really like while they're hot I think
taste wise there are some slight
differences as well there is like
something more than just kind of like
salt going on here
so I only know this because we made that
fast food chemistry episode of
McDonald's fries
but there is like a sort of artificial
beef flavor that's added to these and
you do kind of taste it it's very subtle
but there's like a kind of like Savory
depth of flavor to these that you just
don't get in the UK
I kind of like it I can't lie first
thing about these fries these guys are
pale looking not the bright yellow I'm
used to in the states the whole thing is
this this is potato salt and oil that's
it
yeah
and I believe it because these are bland
man
what no in the fries USA ones are way
better and then finally this enormous
McDonald's Coke
I don't know what it is about McDonald's
Coke but it just always hits different
that happens in the UK and yeah kind of
still happens here another iconic menu
item that I thought was worth trying was
McNuggets so just visually speaking
before I even try it these look quite
different to British McNuggets I'm
fairly sure the ones in the UK are deep
fried correct me if I'm wrong editor but
these ones look almost more deep fried
somehow just in terms of the way that
the breading has kind of like puffed up
and blisted a little bit I also I think
the breading maybe has slightly more
seasoning a bit more flavor going on
here than I'm used to the chicken itself
I think is pretty much the same I think
I might prefer British nuggets I'm sorry
guys nuggets look like almost exactly
the same size
smell the same
same amount of crispness on the skin
no much blander much blander you guys
are getting you guys are getting a
terrible deal with these nuggets because
this is dry I didn't know it says 100
chicken breast meat on this one I do not
know if that's the case in America if we
get that on screen
but I've just been informed no of the
chicken that they use 100 of it is
chicken breast Meats but it's only 45
chicken right it says 100 chicken breast
on it that the implication there is that
the chicken is 100 chicken or it's 100
chicken meat it is not deceptive the
last thing we wanted to compare in both
countries was the mcrispie
here is an American mcrispie it looks
fairly similar to ours on the surface
this one I think is a potato roll rather
than kind of the more like pretzly
brioche version that you find in the UK
there's no sauce
it's just pickles
and a fried chicken patty I really like
the pickles I think pickles and fried
chicken is a great combination and it's
not super common in the UK I will say I
think it needs a sauce I think
technically they claim that they butter
the rolls and that butter is I guess
there for the sauce
but like it's it's kind of dry the
chicken's just like a little bit thin as
well I feel like they look crispy in the
UK tends to be like a thicker and
slightly juicier piece of chicken
this is like a fairly thin
and quite dry chicken breast in a crispy
oh nice all right I'm pleasantly
surprised by the bun like reminds me
like King's Hawaiian rolls yeah this
looks like our McChicken it is so close
to the McChicken better bun
then the McChicken but the crispiness of
the chicken patty it tastes slightly
different I would say to make chicken
sauce as I hate to say it is a bit
sweeter but because I love the McChicken
like the taste of that is like in My DNA
here are all the US menu items you won't
find at a UK McDonald's here's all the
UK McDonald's menu items I can't get in
the U.S we'll start with some chicken
options namely the deluxe mcrispie and
these spicy deluxe look crispy let's
take a look at the deluxe mcrispie and
see what exactly they're adding to make
it Deluxe the roll looks pretty much the
same as the standard version the chicken
looks the same but I think when they say
Deluxe that just means they've added
mayo lettuce and tomato I don't know if
that is enough to qualify something as
Deluxe doesn't seem Super Deluxe to me I
also think that tomato is just a bad
topping for a burger they've kind of
made this worse in my opinion I'm gonna
take a bite of the spicy one and see if
it's good and if it's spicy it does have
some heat to it they won't get them for
my measly British person palette I think
I would probably just buy the regular
version of them at crispy and then like
add some sauce to it so you got a bacon
Mayo chicken and a Mayo with mayo
chicken now this might be exactly what
the McChickens like
um no it's a little wimpier yeah this is
like since we're talking about like it's
a big McNugget
the Mayo's weird because we're like
stale aftertaste I'm telling you your
guys's breaded chicken at McDonald's has
no flavor compared to one in the U.S uh
then a crispy was crispier had more
flavor in the sauce and the bun was
nicer yeah this is like uh it's a bummer
uh the same with bacon but I really have
to no no like flimsy your bacon is not
worth some beef options starting with
the McDouble I have just some kind of
like existential questions about the
McDouble namely why does it exist
because we have the double cheeseburger
give it a try I'm genuinely curious like
how is this different to just a double
cheeseburger slice of cheese one slice
of cheese Joe says one slice of cheese
talk me through it okay so what's going
on here is that the the McDouble has one
slice of cheese in between we're double
cheese we have two slices of cheese oh I
think that's the only difference I
honestly think it's right because this
is just like the standard yeah this is
very normal there's just one less slice
of cheese from what we can tell and the
price difference is let's get that on
screen uh so if you want to save that
amount of money get yourself a McDouble
and uh the past the savings on to you
there you go cheers Joe you had it here
first next up we have the quarter
pounder with cheese deluxe so similarly
to the crispy they've turned this thing
into a deluxe burger by just adding some
lettuce some mayo and some tomato you
know what they've tried to do here
they've tried to just make a Whopper
this is the double quarter pounder with
bacon
now this is a burger
this one does what you would expect a
quarter pounder to do it's just loads of
meat and cheese
I want to talk more about this bacon as
well because this Bacon's good one thing
that I think we do quite badly in the UK
at fast food is bacon a lot of the bacon
you'll find on UK restaurants uh is like
this very pallid pink color whereas this
one stronger flavor you get some like
smokiness from it the bacon on this is
way better and therefore that makes it a
very enjoyable Burger yes I think the
deluxe should just be more beef and some
bacon rather than vegetables that no one
wants to eat come on
yeah now we're talking two patties
although I'm telling you guys the Patty
on Patty with nothing in the middle it's
just weird a poppy sesame seed bun
hybrid
whoa yeah it doesn't look barbecue sauce
like barbecue sauce like an Amber Brown
it's like the bacon kind of screws it up
because your bacon is so flimsy I think
this would work with like American bangs
American bacon which is like
crisp I mean it's not like it has a bit
crispier it's just this is like really
like rubbery what do you guys think
barbecue sauce is
bacon double cheeseburger I'm not
impressed with your bacon here guys I'm
not in look at
yeah like I'm pretty sure we had a bacon
double cheeseburger at some point in
McDonald's and it wasn't like this our
bacon is like crispier more dispersed
evenly I guess it's like two strips
going right through the middle here
that's a disaster the total disaster
Nick plant Harry get in here and explain
to me what I'm doing what this is uh
this is the mcpart it's McDonald's fake
meat Burger it took them ages to develop
this they tested it in Scandinavia first
it was available in Sweden for a while
they also developed their own vegan
cheese because McDonald's couldn't find
a commercial vegan cheese that I thought
was good enough yeah I believe it look
at this this looks terrifying thanks bud
what he said I think it was only
available in a few places in the U.S
came and went
so at least the US audience not
impressed with the mcplant
yeah I'm not going there's definitely
some plant-based meat that tastes good
that tastes like meat this ain't it I
want to take this moment to try your UK
Coca-Cola
man the coke here is way better you guys
make with the real sugar
off with this does this and these are
the dippers right
who do you think you are McDonald's who
do you think you are doing this you just
took the difference
oh God gross what is this like what is
this
vegetables
yo this sucks ass dude yeah the
vegetarian says he loves him put an
asterisk next to that of all the things
you can eat at McDonald's there's two
right and this is one of them so okay
great I never want this
I'm moving on ah chicken selects this is
closer to like what our McChicken and
our nuggets taste like
oh yeah damn which made us in America
the sour cream and chive dip is really
good here are all the exclusive wraps
and salads that you can find in the US
that you won't find in the UK that's not
a mistake there are just none of them
it's not even that there's no exclusives
there's just no wraps or salads Full
Stop on a U.S McDonald's menu
shade I can't exactly say that the UK
salads are good at McDonald's but at
least we have them you know you have an
option if you somehow are trying to eat
healthy but have ended up in a
McDonald's anyway whereas in America the
closest thing you have to a salad is bag
of apple slices oh God
hate wraps this is a really smart way of
presenting this a pita
is that a pita
oh yeah I guess it's closer to a
tortilla
Peter how you said
no that's wrong this is an eye PETA
I would say well you'd be wrong
well it says garlic Bob
not very garlicky okay so then we have
the grilled version of this yeah
no no no no no
what flavor could this possibly have
oh come on
a bit of bread no come on oh man it has
no flavor
yeah you can get a grilled or crispy
chicken salad but we didn't get them
because I didn't fly across the planet
to eat a salad hey this is fun nacho
cheese wedges well we're much further
from Mexico
so how good could the nacho cheese
actually be
not bad it's really the most flavorful
thing I've eaten today now it's time for
the exclusive condiments and you know
what that means this is a sauce talk
the very first sauce talk foreign
exchange sauce talk we're gonna start
with this one spicy buffalo
yeah so I think that's the same one that
they put on the spicy mcrispie
it's pretty good it's basically like if
you take a mayo and just pour some
Frank's Red Hot in it let's try the
honey mustard out I personally love a
honey mustard
you certainly get the honey it's pretty
good I think the balance of that is more
on the honey side
and it needs to swing slightly more to
the mustard side now this one I'm
excited for it's Ranch we call it Ranch
not Ranch
yeah that's pretty good yeah it's got
like a sort of Herby Tang to it then
we've got a couple of condiments which
are technically breakfast items but
we're going to count under Source talk
anyway we'll start with the mild Picante
salsa I think this is supposed to be
paired with the breakfast burrito which
we will get on to later but I'm going to
try it with a nugget
laughs
okay that's enough
that's what it says on the tin I'd say
I'm just a mild sauce already also on
the breakfast Economist list we have hot
cake syrup
I guess like maybe legally they're not
allowed to call it maple syrup so hot
cake syrup
I mean like people eat pancakes with
bacon and maple syrup so why can't
chicken nuggets and maple syrup good
together
okay I thought I thought I'd invented
something special there but
that turns out I cannot claim that
combination as my own it's better they
have butter on the menu I think again
designed to be used with the hot cakes
the final condiment option is some grape
Jam
I will say like we don't tend to have
many grape flavored products in the UK
for whatever reason
yeah
they're pretty tasty yeah I mean like
maybe not in combination with the
chicken but the grape Jam is quite nice
alrighty your ketchup it's bizarre it
makes sense
why this would be ketchup considering
what ketchup is but American ketchup is
way sweeter I don't know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing but like I'm eating
that and I'm like
if that was on a plate I was eating
someone that was on a plate and I was
like dipping into it I'd be like oh what
sauce is this because I wouldn't think
that's ketchup like oh it's like this
fun like tomato sauce you guys like I
wouldn't go oh ketchup yeah it's like
that different okay the barbecue sauce
from the country with no barbecue
let's see what you got let's see what
you guys think barbecue is nope I don't
know what this is supposed to be sweet
chili dip here we go better
just okay McDonald's barbecue sauce is
its own special brand of barbecue sauce
yeah this is pretty close to a bug
this one has a little this one's a
little more mustardy
so okay yeah it's not bad
all right sweet and sour ooh that's
really good oh hell yeah dude sweet
Curry been waiting for this that's
really good we don't have any exclusive
options when it comes to the food inside
a Happy Meal but I did want to get one
and just kind of like see what the vibe
was see what the toy is crucially
so at the time of recording this uh The
Little Mermaid photos recently so they
seem to be doing a collab with the
little mermaid
does that mean I'm gonna get a Little
Mermaid toy let's find out
so we go oh these fries are so cute so
this is a UK large
foreign
this is what I'm used to I'm also in the
UK the fries come in like a paper bag
rather than one of these Simply Adorable
little uh cartons which honestly huge
fan of I went for the McNuggets which
tend to come in a box of four
there you go you get the apple slices
within that this is the American salad
and of course we get a toy oh it's King
Triton let's go place your toy on a
phone or tablet for more fun
which I do think we have to try and do
real quick okay put it down put my phone
on the on the desk yeah you guys are
getting the table getting all this this
is this is crucial
take a thing I'll just go there okay
Play It Again turn your sound on
I'm gonna be honest this is uh this is a
mess some kind of pattern learn pattern
that one that one
did it I win DC Happy Meal
I've been told that it's a toy oh poison
ivy fast food fish is way more popular
here you guys love your fast fish I do
not
smells fishy
for the first time your food being
flavorless is a good time fries yeah
this is actually I would say this is
also our kid's size let's take a look at
the poison ivy to it what's that what
okay oh there's some inside
stickers
again all right fun for kids
now we're into some Cafe and dessert
options unfortunately I couldn't get a
few of these but here are the ones that
I was able to find today we'll start
with a good old-fashioned American
chocolate chip cookie this looks pretty
good we're kind of bad at cookies in the
UK I don't know what it is but they tend
to be very like dry and crumbly rather
than soft and chewy
what's more American than apple pie I'll
tell you what an apple pie from
McDonald's
this is the American McDonald's apple
pie in the UK a McDonald's apple pie is
actually deep fried it just looks very
different this is a baked apple pie so
you get more of like a lattice going on
you see the filling there but it's baked
so I guess you know they don't need to
seal it on every side because it's not
going in a fryer it's not going to spill
out into the oil I don't know if it's
going to hold up or not
I think the UK might be doing better
apple pies than the US's at least when
it comes to McDonald's the pastry is
fine
the filling tastes pretty much identical
to the filling of a UK apple pie
but yeah like the baked pastry is just
not the same as fried pastry and then
there's actually another pie option on
the menu right now at a US McDonald's
this one is a strawberry cream pie
that's pretty good as I said there were
some desserts and pastries that we
weren't able to get today here they are
in the UK you can also get exclusive
McFlurries could not get them because
you're not going to believe it but the
ice cream machines are also broken in
the UK you can get yourself a maltesers
McFlurry and a smarties McFlurry okay we
got them the cafe snacks
first up oh a donut hey it doesn't like
a donut oh yo this one is covered in
Sugar look at that muffin Berry
muffin a Millionaire's donut huh
oh with the with the cream inside it is
pretty decadent I don't know if I feel
like a millionaire I don't think
Millionaire's reading those I'm gonna be
honest with you
well hell yeah
yeah yup that's a good cookie let's talk
about the drinks first of all there are
some hot and cold coffees which are
available in both countries it does seem
like the US actually has a bigger range
of coffees particularly when it comes to
the iced versions while in the UK we're
limited to a couple of basic ones like
an ice latte over here you can get all
sorts you can get things like your iced
caramel mocha yeah frappa mocha Chino
Duncan thingy majiggy you know the ones
there are some interesting non-coffee
drinks though that I do want to try and
talk about now we'll start with this one
down the end which I believe is Hawaiian
Punch
not common in the UK at all
yep okay
if this is the first one I think I have
a bit of a storm coming here it's pretty
good but wow is that sweet this one is
an American style lemonade as I've said
before in the show lemonade in the UK is
like Sprite it's like a clear carbonated
lemony beverage whereas this looks like
a good old-fashioned American lemonade
it's not bad it's weird like to me that
lemonade isn't carbonated but that's
pretty good that's actually fairly
refreshing unlike maybe the Hawaiian
Punch was also uh Happy Birthday Grimace
while we're on the subject they did have
a special Grimace Shake but the ice
cream machine was broken at the
McDonald's that we went to of course so
I haven't been able to get the Grimace
show which I'm really sad about here's
what it's supposed to look like
they do not have a good old-fashioned
cup of tea on the menu at an American
McDonald's what they do have is sweet
tea I felt like I had to try it as a
Brit you know I have to give my thoughts
on everyone's teas
no they weren't kidding when they called
it sweet tea
um so this was supposed to be a blue
raspberry frozen Fanta and this was
supposed to be a frozen Coke however now
it is just a melted blue raspberry Fanta
and a melted Coke otherwise known as
Coke
oh
that's pretty good
just Taste of coke it does somehow like
still has a bit of Fizz to it and the
same with the Fanta actually I do think
I would like these if they were frozen I
think like on a really hot day for
example carrying a frozen Coke around
sounds delightful so yeah uh would quite
like those on the UK menu maybe then we
have a what I believe to be high C drink
high C orange lava burst yeah so this
isn't carbonated but it's not fruit
juice it's somewhere in the middle
I'd put it like reasonably close to an
oasis that we can get in the UK which is
also like a sort of non-carbonated
fruity beverage I don't love it last but
by no means least we have milk on the
menu I think this is kind of aimed at
kids I never want to meet a person who
is a grown adult and goes to McDonald's
and orders milk with their meal these
are all the exclusive drinks we got
today there are some other ones and here
they are the McCafe exclusives uh they
didn't label any of them so I'll just
guess that's definitely hot chocolate
but let's see what it causes it compared
to the deluxe
um
oh this is the butter thing that's
terrible we'll get back to that let me
find the other hot chocolate
that's a hot chocolate
I can't tell the difference I don't know
which ones would Deluxe be size
wait this one has like that buttery oil
floating in it and this
I know what this is tea
I don't get it I don't get why this is
so popular then the cafe food's pretty
good I like it you got a good selection
here the drinks not so much I like
banana I like banana flavored stuff and
we don't nearly have as much in the
United States this tastes exactly like a
banana Laffy Taffy it's great what's
Oasis
yeah I don't think
and it's like sweet but it like reminds
me like Gatorade
um orange juice I know what orange juice
tastes like what is this Robinson's
fruit shoot why is it a Fruit Shoot
what's the shooting part
oh so this is like shoot in the mouth
then what
I would like to know why this is called
Fruit Shoot okay so I think it's called
I've even looked at it I think it's
called fruit shoe because I want you to
squeeze like shooting your mouth
uh and Leon thinks it's because it
sounds better than saying Coke now we're
going to talk about the most important
meal of the day breakfast we'll start
with this one the steak and egg McMuffin
that doesn't really look taste or feel
like a steak now next up America has
some breakfast biscuit options so from
what I've seen a biscuit looks very much
like a scone which is obviously a
classic British dish now the fact that
they would be putting breakfast food
like bacon eggs sausages into what is
effectively a scone is weird to me and I
think will be weird to a lot of Brits as
well so this is just a classic sausage
biscuit it looks does look pretty like a
scone it's maybe a bit more like Smooth
on the outside than I'm expecting from a
scone
food Wars here I just wanted to say
that's not a scone it's a different
biscuit I don't know what he's talking
about he'll be chewing on that for the
next four minutes but it's different
he's right it's different it's not a
scum it's somehow worse yeah apparently
I chose badly with the sausage being my
first one because that was dry as a
desert so let's have a quick bite of a
bacon egg and cheese which is a classic
American slash New York breakfast combo
they're still pretty dry but the
addition of the other stuff definitely
helps what are the takeaways there
um scones and biscuits are different not
the same it's gone is a little bit more
crumbly generally like slightly sweeter
these are not sweet slightly more bready
texture
I'm still not convinced by the notion of
them as like the foundation of a
breakfast sandwich just mostly because
of how dry they are but hey who am I to
uh judge American culture now these I'm
excited for I've heard very good things
about these from Joe these are
McDonald's McGriddles if I remember
correctly from watching Joey these
they've kind of got like pancakes that
they sort of inject with syrup and then
use those as the buns for a breakfast
sandwich which sounds pretty excellent
I'll try the bacon egg and cheese see
how we get them
still slightly dry but way less driving
the biscuit and very tasty I'm gonna go
even more syrup because what's better
than adding more syrup to something
which is already full of syrup
McGriddles yes
biscuits
not so sure so this was the bacon egg
and cheese McGriddle you can also get
McGriddles with sausage sausage and egg
and cheese or the steak which I will not
be trying the next exclusive breakfast
item is the bacon egg and cheese
breakfast bagel we used to have Bagels
on the menu at the UK McDonald's and
they were wonderful part of the
breakfast menu toasted bagels with your
choice of toppings and fillings really
good pandemic hit they cut them from the
menu and they've not returned and
personally I'm furious about that
yeah they've missed you so much Bagel
next up we have a sausage burrito
breakfast burrito is really not a thing
in the UK
we're just like generally bad at Mexican
food this is obviously designed to be
enjoyed with the mild salsa it's
actually pretty good and the last thing
on the breakfast menu we have these the
big breakfasts the standard big
breakfast is a slab of scrambled egg
a sausage patty and a biscuit and this
is the big breakfast with hot cakes
which is the egg biscuit and sausage but
then also comes with two pancakes both
of these come with dips including a
little thing of whipped butter and of
course the hot cake syrup so I wasn't
sure what the difference was between
pancakes and Hot Cakes Josh has done a
quick Google and apparently Hot Cakes
tend to be a bit thicker and denser than
pancakes I mean to me that just tastes
like a pancake I'm thinking maybe
they've just called hot them hotcakes to
make them sound more fancy or different
but yeah not bad and of course
McDonald's UK I gotta try the breakfast
all right first up the mini potato
waffles hash browns are shaped like a
waffle I don't know why this specific
shape
oh
yeah dude for some reason it tastes a
lot better in Waffle form I don't know
why that is it is really good what do
you got here breakfast sandwich
this is the bacon roll with brown sauce
a burger bun
look at this
there's your brown sauce right there
it's just okay nothing special
it's a bland
I'm starting to I'm starting to think
that you in the UK you guys don't like
your stuff isn't as like intense as ours
in America is like this wouldn't fly in
the U.S
because it's not dripping with cheese
and it doesn't have an egg in it and the
Buns aren't like uber buttery
is this too plain it's too boring this
is the same thing with just ketchup
oh
now we're getting more in my speed
this one has cheese and bacon in it oh
yeah is that sausage
yeah this looks more like something
they'd get in the U.S
yeah
cheesy flatbread oh God
cheesy come on guys yeah see this is the
bacon this is more like the bacon we're
used to so that's
streaky bacon so this is bacon and the
other thing was Canadian bacon in the
U.S
I don't know why or or ham I'm gonna
call it I mean this just looks like I
mean this looks like whatever
yes sir and that's why it sucks it's
like the the flatbread is too strong I
can barely taste the streaky bacon which
is the weather came here for so double
sausage okay so with this you guys just
went double meat on both
yeah this now we're talking UK see
although nothing in between the two
sausage patties is like you gotta like
it's Gotta Go cheese meat cheese meat
you can't just do meat this like this
this this doesn't work and possibly like
a sauce no sauce is weird for this one
your sausage is weird I would say ours
is like spicier not heat but like the
flavor of the sausage is more pronounced
in the US One compared to this so I know
in the US our sausage is made up of
and from what I understand the UK
sausage is made up of
and that was all done in post I have no
idea what it says I I do like seriously
thing I like the double but needs more
cheese needs to be drowning in some sort
of sauce but this one I'm assuming that
is
uh double bacon
I don't know this is not double bacon
wait skip one two pieces of Bacon's
double bacon
this is double for you guys for real yo
you're getting ripped off guys excuse me
you've made a mistake I'm gonna come
back in like come like storming and cut
the line be like ah you made a mistake
on mine there's only one slice of bacon
on this so all right let's try let's try
with this double bacon
I mean it's ham
yeah that's standard that's not
that's not double this is smart that
they did the G I don't know if they in
the US they have the squirtable one I
mean do I need to like I mean I know
what a muffin and jam tastes like I'm
not like
if I eat this will I still have had a
British buff in a gym I think after this
I still have no idea what a British
muffin and jam tastes like all right all
right all right all right everyone relax
oh yeah it's really good
this tastes way better than the crap
that we have like way better sorry I've
just been informed that in England these
are just called muffins not English
muffins porridge
I'm from the US I don't know what
porridge is I'm assuming it's oatmeal
so from what I can tell you can porch
four different ways one with golden
syrup looks a lot like honey one with
strawberry jam straight from France one
with uh sugar which they did not include
and then one plain so first I'm just
going
straight forage No Chaser yeah there's
no flavor to it
yeah all right so I've been informed
that golden syrup is good stuff
I don't know what's interesting golden
syrup and I guess whatever other syrups
you're right it's like it's not quite
maple syrup but it's pretty close
makes it much better obviously
all right overall area of the American
exclusives what were some of your likes
and some of your dislikes
some of the things I liked uh you guys
have a much bigger breakfast menu than
we do I did like them at griddles they
did live up to uh Joe's pretty high
billing
I also think that your bacon is much
better than ours so I think maybe the
double quarter pounder with bacon was uh
was a strong highlight there
some dislikes
um
there's a few I don't like the biscuits
I'm sorry guys I think they are like for
a British person too similar to a scon
so we can't really like mentally
differentiate between the two and it's
just quite dry
um and also I think like making your
Burgers Deluxe by just adding loads of
mayo some tomato and lettuce just is a
bit underwhelming not really a deluxe
Vibe for me one thing to the UK from the
US exclusive what would it be if I could
take one of these exclusives that I've
tried today back to the UK with me for
our menu I think I'm gonna have to pick
the bacon egg and cheese McGriddle I
think it was really good it's a bit of a
Twist on the classic McMuffin formula
feels like a little bit more decadent
maybe a little bit more sweet
um and yeah just uh really good fun I
like the emphasis you guys place on your
breakfast menu
but the thing that I hated the most and
would want to remove from all possible
menus
It's Tricky there were there were a
couple
but I think it might have to be the
sausage biscuit it was so dry and the
notion of a biscuit slash scone
breakfast sandwich to a British person
is just too bizarre I can't get mad
around it and uh yeah not the best now
yeah I really disliked your bacon your
bacon is weird
it ruined everything that I was on I
love bacon but your bacon is just it is
bizarre but things I like the most I
obviously like the curry dipping sauce I
like the banana milkshake separately
obviously that that triple chocolate
chip cookie was good
uh I'm taking back the the curry dipping
sauce I wanted to try that since we shot
the first episode
um and then take off your menu
I mean those veggie Dippers were pretty
dismal but I don't want to leave
vegetarians out in the Lurch the thing
that's like haunting me the most was the
grilled chicken wrap I don't think it
was grilled I think it was boiled and uh
I feel bad that that's on your menu and
it's gross and I will I will do the UK
favor all grilled chicken off the menu
McDonald's you're welcome
all right
[Applause]
go inside take a look around and see how
it compares to a British McConnell
experience